hablemos primero del avance de Wagner
porque el interés de este grupo
Mercenario en restov donde dicen haber
tomado el cuartel militar es esta una
ciudad estratégica tal vez bueno está
buscando un Punto de partida dentro del
territorio ruso donde establecer su base
de operaciones evidentemente y rostov se
prestaba en la misma medida en que no no
estaba previsto que pudiera haber una
situación de este tipo han tomado
El Comando estratégico dentro de la
ciudad y Consecuentemente van a
utilizarlo como una base para
avanzar hacia Moscú como es la intención
en este momento y se está desarrollando
no
claro ahora de qué dependerá que puedas
seguir avanzando camino hacia Moscú
porque de acuerdo con los reportes Se
podría decir que no se han encontrado
con ninguna resistencia significa esto
una falta de preparación por parte de
Rusia no yo creo que lo que pasa que es
muy compleja la situación interna entre
las distintas fuerzas de seguridad en
Rusia hay el Gro que es la inteligencia
militar que de alguna manera ha estado
apoyando a pregogen y está bajo su ala
digamos institucionalmente Pero además
están en las fuerzas regulares están la
el fcb que es el servicio de seguridad
del estado de inteligencia Y por otra
parte también las distintas fuerzas como
la de Cadilla que son están las mismas
condiciones que Wagner y
fundamentalmente todo esto gira en torno
a la figura de Putin entonces Quiénes
responden a Putin y Quienes no hasta
ahora pareciera que las tres últimas que
he mencionado están respondiendo a Putin
y eventualmente puede llegar a haber
alguna reacción y la decisión
planteada por lo menos anunciada por
Putin en su conferencia última es muy
clara de que bueno pregogen es un
traidor y Consecuentemente será juzgado
como tal y de hecho ya se ha iniciado un
proceso de acuerdo a la ley
antiterrorista en función de lo que se
ha promovido dentro de del sistema
judicial ruso no y es que esta situación
se da en un momento clave justo cuando
Ucrania lanzada su contraofensiva podría
estar rebelión ofrecer algún tipo de
ventaja a las fuerzas ucranianas
mientras Moscú se concentra ahora en
frenar el avance de Wagner
es posible pero hay distintas
interpretaciones dadas todas las falta
de transparencia en este proceso y no
sabemos muy bien si aparte de los
conflictos internos dentro de la ley
militar rusa
qué es lo que se está desarrollando no
lo tenemos con mucha Claridad lo que es
cierto es que hay dos estructuras con
mandos militares distintos en este caso
Wagner y la fuerza regulares Y eso no
son esa situación no es compatible y la
decisión última la ha tomado Putin en el
sentido de favorecer las estructuras
formales formalmente establecidas
entonces de ahí en adelante veremos Cómo
se desarrolla pero Aparentemente por lo
menos no he tenido información sobre que
esto en lo inmediato haya afectado a la
capacidad defensiva de la fuerza de las
tropas rusas en la línea de frente con
Ucrania